there has never been a low with me
wearing a shoe there's never been a
worry about oh i stepped my shoe in the
mud or i spilled a fruit punch you know
on my shoes or whatever the case may be
i've never been that type of person
shoes are meant to be worn they're
supposed to have their own lives and
they own stories
[Music]
i can think of any other shoe that has
amazing significance i've always loved
wwe i was a big john cena fan and i
remember he was wearing these these
shoes that pump up and i was like man
what what should he keep pumping up and
then he going and hit someone with the
attitude adjustment which we ain't have
no money i mean
and making ends meet week by week was
already hard enough now you got me
saying hey dad you know i think i can
get my basketball game to the next level
if you put the right shoes on my feet
and it was my birthday coming i was like
you know what for my birthday i don't
want nothing else but just these pumps
and he found a way to get me them i
remember he worked some overtime and got
me those shoes my dad already worked six
jobs so the fact that he had to do
overtime on top of six jobs shows you
the commitment he did to get me the
shoes and man i was pumping some things
everywhere you i walked outside pumped
mom said something punk was on the court
pump score basket pump celebration like
i had it all going with the pump those
homes have a great story with me they
have a great time in my life as well
this shoe these were playoff ps that
were only made for the playoffs i
designed it in a way
where the person wearing the shoe will
find motivation every single day and
wearing the shoe and they may see
something different every day that may
give them a more of a drive to keep
going you see a lot of
sayings that i thought of or i have been
told just breathe
be positive be you believe if i was a
little kid and i was playing the game of
basketball and maybe i'm not doing as
well as i wanted to do that shoe could
give you a reminder just to breathe
enjoy life enjoy the moment enjoy the
present because the future is
imagination and the past is learning and
the gift so i wanted to create something
more of like a movement of culture
something that breeds positivity and
great mental health
i think it's always about telling the
story of the shoe without having to
physically write the story out for
people i want to do something that has
materials that come from
uh dominican republic doing something
super cool and different like
incorporating cane sugar from dr into
the soul and materials that come from
africa and finding ways to get some of
the fabrics uh for the shoes that i
could have resemblance of being back to
the motherland i think the shoe should
have versatility so maybe like a mid you
know kind of like a mid feeling
basketball shoe or a lifestyle shoe
where it could go with the high feel it
could go with the low feel if you wanted
to skateboard in it you can if you
wanted to play basketball at a high
level in it you can there's a lot of
work to do but the actual execution of
it uh
you never know it gave me an idea maybe
i'll start one